[Musique]
mon amour à zain pour jour oui bonjour
vous êtes donc la représentante de l'eau
angie internationale care oui je suis
donc des lectrices du programme pour
care international zidane
alors vous vous trouvez au zimbabwe en
ce moment et on sait que cette
population là vient de vivre un
phénomène apocalyptique
dites moi c'est quoi le portrait de la
situation aujourd'hui en fait c'est ça
le cyclone a frappé les façons assez
longtemps une entendu en matière de
magnitude ou deux
des dommages et des décès aussi les
mauvais sont habitués à avoir beaucoup
depuis deux saisons assez prévisible
mais ce coup ci le cyclone a été
vraiment très puissant et ont causé
beaucoup beaucoup de manger des décès
donc ça va être vraiment chamboulé la
population et vit en fait des fêtes de
la difficulté qu'on aime le plus dans
les premiers jours de la réponse
d'urgence et elle accepte donc les zones
touchées
en fait certaines des journées plus
touché hors d'accès aux agences de lui
même table donc des routes détruites par
les inondations les glissements de
terrain il ya eu des ponts effondrés
donc vraiment l'accès aux victimes
étaient très très difficile d' 1 mais
non commence à voir une certaine
amélioration
donc depuis hier qu'elle a été en mesure
de départ la distribution dans les
régions les plus affectées
on a bien commencé dans les jours
précédents dans les régions plus facile
d'accès donc oui essentiellement c'est
un sillon qui est normalement de damages
on a vu des images qui révèle une
situation assez dramatique un difficile
pour ces populations là qui en plus de
pleurer leurs morts ont toujours les
pieds dans l'eau on imagine que suit le
plan sanitaire ça doit être très très
difficile
oui tout à fait c'est vraiment une de
nos priorités à coeur on a commencé
distribution de produits center et d'eau
d'assainissement
c'est vraiment une priorité parce que on
sait que dans ces situations les
inondations pour les puits sont
consommés en contaminer les gens
n'arrivent pas à trouver des sources
d'eau potable donc son devoir se
résoudre à voir de l'eau contaminée ils
n'ont pas les ressources pour faire en
sorte de décontaminer de purifier l'eau
donc c'est vraiment ça qu'on est
mobilisé dans les premiers première
journée de la réponse de distribution de
ses produits le cynisme en deux lots et
l'équipement à voir avec
l'assainissement et viennent donc placé
population losc en mesure de de prévenir
un flop d'attraper des maladies sont
communiquées par l'eau comme le choléra
et au regard de l'étendue du problème on
imagine que l'aide doit être vraiment
urgente et importante
est-ce que care travaille en partenariat
avec d'autres organisations sur le
terrain oui donc dans ces quartiers de
réponse urgente donc et beaucoup de
coordination
parce que je crois c'est complexe sur le
terrain de coordination avec le
gouvernement avec les organismes des
nations unies avec d'autres ong
donc c'est vraiment essayé de voir où
sont les besoins et rouky peut
travailler ou afin qu'on soit vraiment
en mesure de rejoindre jugeant possible
et ne pas dupliquer les efforts
finalement on sait que le gouvernement
canadien a toujours fait preuve d'une
certaine sollicitude en pareilles
circonstances
est ce que pour le moment on peut
chiffrer l'aide du canada dans ce pays
dans le besoin
à ma connaissance il on a fait une
déclaration de 1.5 millions je crois
mais oui en fait on attend toujours de
l'inde
les gouvernements à ce moment là ils ont
par leur recherche de financement
en ce moment il ya beaucoup de
gouvernements qui ont fait des
engagements en fait promener en réponse
prenez en réponse aux gens affectés par
les cylons et quelles sont les
principales difficultés rencontrées sur
le terrain au-delà des contraintes liées
à ce cyclone là est ce qu'il ya des
problèmes par exemple réglementaire
est-ce que sur le plan politique les
autorités sont assez ouverte à la
coopération internationale
donc tous tout projet développement à
long terme sont en coopération avec le
gouvernement
et c'est la même chose au niveau des
urgences donc c'est eux qui qu'ils
assument le leadership de la réponse
d'urgence donc mais évidemment ils ont
pas que tous les ressources pour
incapable de venir en langue donc des
problèmes première journée du skins
ils ont en fait déclaré l'urgence est
demandé assistance incluant et bien
voilà madame morazin je vous remercie
infiniment d'avoir pris le temps de nous
parler aujourd'hui
je signale que vous êtes donc la
représentante de l'omg internationale
care qui fait un travail remarquable sur
le terrain et qui vient en aide à ces
populations sinistrées après le passage
d'un cyclone dévastateur dans leur pays
merci beaucoup madame morazin merci à
vous au revoir au revoir